the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
good afternoon so last time we talked
about neuropsychiatric disorder and I
just want to remind you that we talked
about in a couple of context of
challenges that historically different
cultures at different times have
interpreted unusual behavior in very
different ways from trephination where
you have to release evil spirits to to
possession to group what we would now
consider brutal patterns of taking
people away from society who behave
unusually and that even in recent times
things like in the Soviet Union the
diagnosis of people who protest a
totalitarian governments you know is a
socially defined diagnosis obviously
things like definition of homosexuality
is a psychiatric disorder until about
twenty years ago with a socially defined
disorder so there's a lot of challenges
on the other hand there's a lot of
people suffering with a huge range of
neuropsychiatric disorders so we're
going to talk some more about that today
about think about a little bit more
about issues of treatment talk a bit
about depression and ADHD and I think of
depression and ADHD attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder as a kind of
different than schizophrenia so most of
us except for the one percent
approximately who have schizophrenia
you know don't hear voices right that's
an unusual thing but all of us can be
sad and many children are what we would
consider to be a bit hyperactive
compared to a teenager or an adult right
you know they won't sit still quietly in
a large classroom like this for very
long and so when we talk about disorders
like these these are in some ways
exaggerations or extensions of what we
consider typical everyday behavior but
moving into a realm that makes life
difficult for those who get the
diagnosis so when it comes to treatment
they're served two giant classes of them
one of them is behavioral treatment
broadly speaking you who call them talk
therapies and the other one is medical
treatment with drugs within
psychotherapy which really covers all of
of talk therapies people sometimes make
a distinction between psychoanalysis and
cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT so
what is psychological therapy so it says
he might have a sense that there's a lot
of organization and rules and regulation
about this but the truth of the matter
is that psychotherapy is a social
interaction which a trained professional
tries to help another person behave and
feel differently there's really no
boundaries on that okay there's no
official rules there's more and less
official channels you're used to but it
can be a very wide sources of this and
if you flip open this is an archaic
thing yellow pages I realize just a few
years ago people yellow pages
but these said things called phones and
phone books that were tethered to the
wall and this is where you would look
for information about people who lists
themselves as providing psychotherapy
all you have to do is put your name in
that listing even easier on the internet
maybe psychiatrists the big difference
between psychiatrists and a practical in
one practical sense and psychologist a
psychiatrist of course go to medical
school and they have prescription
privileges they can write prescriptions
for drugs that's rare to non-existent
currently among psychologists
psychoanalysis here's Sigmund Freud in
the original psychotherapy couch
and I think we barely mentioned Freud so
far in this course right was it kind of
a big shock to many people if you might
have thought coming into this course
that did be Freud Freud Freud and you
know that we'd be sitting there and that
we'd be discussing ideas about Freudian
theory I'll come back to the moment
clinical psychologists can provide
psychotherapy counseling psychologists
in schools clinical social workers
clergy peer groups self-help books so
let me return to Freud just for a moment
because intellectually I think most
people agree that Freud was a giant mind
and that in many ways the complexity of
the modern human mind the idea that were
made up of different parts different
feelings that were not just one simple
operation machine but that we have
conflicts of different feelings and
thoughts and patterns all within us and
Freud probably articulated that thought
more powerfully than anybody
in many ways as a modern way in which we
view people right people not just simple
things the complicated things full of
tensions and desires that are all mixed
together at the same time the specific
ideas of Freud articulated using three
you know psychodynamic theories of free
association resistance transference
interpretation trying to correct to the
emotional experience where you go back
to your youth and you figure out
something bad that happened and if you
can somehow grapple with that that will
let you be free of the consequences of
that early experience that almost none
of that has withstood the scrutiny of
practical science a lot of it you don't
even know how you could begin to test
now is for those of you who become
physicians and the rest of you will be
patients it's amazing how much in
medicine is not science-based it's
amazing all right so you hear the cry
all the time in medicine we need to have
science or evidence-based medicine and
you might have thought well what else
are they doing okay and the answer is
they're treating as best they can what
works works a lot of stuff they don't
understand exactly when and why it works
but they apply what they can there's a
patient in distress
Freudian ideas are you know everything
that you know about kids and electric
complexes and all that kinds of stuff
hard to prove that they exist in any
scientific sense so weirdly Freud is in
many ways marginalized in current
scientific psychology that doesn't mean
it wasn't a creative mind that
influenced the way people think about
the human mind and treating the human
mind but the specific ideas he has are
in many ways at the edge of the field so
more central to the field is work called
cognitive behavioral therapy or CBT this
is Aaron Beck who's that maybe the
foremost figure in that and that CBT was
developed to be exactly the opposite in
many senses of psychoanalysis so similar
because it's about behavior and about
the interaction between a clinician and
a person seeking a sort of happier
healthier approach to things but you
know the Woody Allen version of
psychotherapy where you go you know for
40 years weekly to your psychiatrist on
the west side and talk through your
problems okay that idea people said well
that's
it's fine if you do that but is that
really what we mean by treating somebody
so Beck said you know things like
anxiety or depression people have
dysfunctional beliefs that the world is
threatening that the world is hopeless
these are sort of logical thinking
errors that you can work yourself out of
to make yourselves left depressed or
less anxious that you should focus not
on childhood causes of what happened but
on current problems you face day to day
and how to grapple with them develop
strategies that don't make you get down
and depressed or fearful and anxious and
that it should be time limited you know
eight weeks or something from beginning
to end period not an endless review of
your life and roots of your life and so
people have liked that because of part
it's easy to test in research studies
it's been shown to be pretty effective
pretty much on a par with medications
and most studies and in some cases
better and you could get psychoanalysis
could go forever it's hard to
experimentally test that in many ways so
there was questions about whether
psychotherapy works and if you're kind
of a scientist you kind of like
biological stuff like pills you know I'm
not talking right although talk is very
powerful and and now an early on people
said well maybe it's all baloney and I
would say you know starting around 1980
from this review people said no there's
a lot to it although not everything we
wish I did
so they performed a meta-analysis you
may have heard of these kinds of things
where as a quantitative method for
averaging results of a large number of
different studies the idea is that
statistically if you combine many
different studies you might have a sort
of an overall picture it's not just
describing them but taking their actual
statistics and combining them looking
for the effect size something about the
consistent size of in this case the
psychotherapy treatment and then asking
what happens in the terms of the effect
size and you come out with a picture
like this in the study that you have an
average effect size of about 0.7 that
has treated people this is getting
better this way we're on average better
across many different studies that the
treatments seem to move people in the
right direction and that furthermore
about 1/2 receiving psychotherapy
about the average person was better
often 80% of people who didn't get it so
not everybody benefits greatly but many
people benefit some about 10% got worse
so this this number says only a few get
worse a weirdly different thing was that
people have always wanted to develop
very clear ideas about which forms of
many possible forms of behavioral
therapy are really powerful through
which difficulty or which kind of person
it makes sense right the different
problem you're facing and the kind of
person you are a different kind of talk
therapy different kind of CBT would be
powerful for you and that's been
incredibly hard to demonstrate in most
cases shockingly hard to demonstrate and
part of that comes from these kinds of
studies so the best of these kinds of
studies have Rand an assignment in two
different kinds of treatment you for
psychotherapy you might have a wait list
and you could be blinded as to getting a
good or bad version so again here's
another meta-analysis and here's the
kind of big surprise again in this other
next meta-analysis about two-to-one
chance of improving versus control if
you sit there and don't do anything so
that's again a good way to go if you're
in distress here's kind of a surprise
credentials don't matter PhD MD no
degree okay there might be something
about the kind of person who's a more or
less effective therapist that's been
hard to scientifically demonstrate the
degree you have has never correlated
with the effectiveness of the treatment
here's another big surprise the
experience of the therapist didn't
matter beginning middle end of career
seen a lot of patients not seen a lot of
patients that doesn't consistently
matter the type of therapy doesn't
consistently matter the length of
therapy doesn't matter okay in any way
that people have been able to show
scientifically what seems to matter is
talking to somebody who listens to you
on a consistent basis yeah
that's for all these kinds of things
right so you know on the one hand he
wouldn't want to push it to an absurdist
thing because if there are humans
involved you want to I say let's just
for fun let's take somebody who's like a
three-year-old right and send them out
to see what they can do right so I mean
yeah there's a real person involved in
real distress so yeah but whenever
they've done these kinds of things yeah
adjusted CBT is the most consistently
studied because it's very organized
psychotherapy so many people do so
differently it's very hard to study so n
CBT is time limited so that has a that
approach seems more practical in some
sense as to people's mind so most of the
research on behavioral therapies that
focused on CBT but not exclusively but
um people have never been able to show
that these things matter you know maybe
there is something about the bedside
matter so to speak of the clinician or
the person who talks with you but that's
never been extracted rigorously then the
other approach of course is of many
different kinds of medications that you
read about or hear about or experience
all the time it's turned out let me just
say we're to be extraordinarily hard to
develop medications for psychiatric
diseases there's been a number that
mostly been discovered by accident most
of these where medications developed for
something else they kind of stumbled on
is useful for psychiatric disorders in
the last 20 years as people have
developed drugs more systematically it's
been brutally hard to develop drugs for
psychiatric disorders there's hardly
been any major new ones in the last 10
years and many pharmaceutical companies
are now abandoning their current
research programs because they just
don't feel they're making any traction
so it's been really really hard I mean
the mind and brain is just so
complicated um so you get all kinds of
partly political debates about people
who are concerned about what's right for
children or be giving kids too many
drugs
of course you're never gonna have a
psychiatric you never gave a scientific
answer to that you know some kids
probably get too many drugs some kids
probably don't get enough we'll come
back and talk about ADHD so let people
let's pick for a moment one disorder and
ask then we'll pick OCD obsessive
compulsive disorder so it's a it is a
kind of an anxiety disorder that
features obsessions recurrent unwanted
thoughts people are drawn to
patterns of thought that they don't want
to over and over again so the obsessions
are mental patterns of thought the
compulsions are physical repetitive
behaviors like endless hand-washing
counting checking and cleaning done with
such intensity and ferocity the person
is really trapped by these so let me
show you one example of an individual
patient describing her experience so the
thing with these disorders is you know
we sometimes say somebody's a little OCD
because they like to you know be extra
careful to brush their teeth
four times a day or you know but within
these cases these individuals are really
trapped I mean they have a hard time
leaving their house a lot hard time
functioning socially hard time getting
jobs so people wonder what's the most
helpful treatment and we here's a
example of a study looking at how many
symptoms you have of OCD and these are
individuals who get in blue placebo so
it's good to be low in green a
medication that's used for the disorder
and in these colors are getting
behavioral treatment or behavioral
treatment plus medication so at least in
this context for example behavioral
treatment is more effective by itself
than the medication it'd be easy to tell
you oh there's a rule for different
disorders that it's behavioral treatment
or medication but it turns out on
average they just vary considerably
depending on the medication depending on
the particular patients you see there's
no real understanding yet of which
patients should get which treatment
under which circumstance and here is
some evidence suggesting that if you get
medication only this is the percent who
relapse so a concern is there's active
treatment phase and how many people
slide back into the difficulty
medication only about half the people
relapsing with about a year later but if
they get this sort of behavioral
treatment there sort of seems to be more
sustained benefits so people are
thinking that might be important and
then if people wonder if we treat your
mind
by behavioral therapy or if we treat
your brain by drugs now we're going to
reject that distinction okay when I talk
to you if you happen to remember
anything I say I'm changing your brain
okay
talk or experience or thoughts or in
that
change your brain as much as any medical
substances right so you know it's a
wrong way to think like the drugs change
the brain and the talk changes the mind
to change your minds to change your
brain so but any case you could ask
whether these forms of treatment in what
ways are they similar or dissimilar so
here's PET scans of patients with OCD
pre and post-treatment
and you can see that there's sort of
hyper activation in the basal ganglia
and the caudate that looks pretty
similar across treatments as if both
treatments were working on that over
activation of the basal ganglia on the
other hand here's looking at CBT and
drug treatment for depression and you
can see these pictures with these blue
areas and these with these red areas the
brain changes in response to treatment
look very different so there's no simple
answer about whether behavioral therapy
and drug therapy changed the same or
different things to help people depends
on the disorder depends on the drug and
you know we just have a lot more to
learn about that but both of those
things affect the brain and can be
effective to help people so let's focus
on depression a little bit these are
people with depression who fear fearful
gloomy helpless hopeless in an extreme
way so that it's difficult to get out of
bed difficult to do work relate to
people historian the literature analyst
description of how weary stale flat and
unprofitable seem to me all the uses of
this world describes often with people
with repression roughly describe their
experiences like a typical episode
it varies widely is about four to twelve
months if untreated of intense
depression a pervasive dysphoria
just certain the ability to feel
pleasure and intense mental pain
generalized loss of interest it's
estimated to sometimes affected some 5%
of the world's population is a huge
number of individuals average age of
onset is thirty but it goes across wide
ages often unnoticed in children people
are picking this up more than they used
to they used to think there's a thought
that children can't really be depressed
it's hard to know why that happens
exactly psychiatric ideas are typically
developed in adults and it takes a while
for the field to recognize them in
children but it's rare to have a fir
depressive episode after 60 it's rare to
have gone your life and then get
depression in older age kind of
mysteriously at the moment
women have depression at two or three
times the rate of men in the United
States and pretty much throughout the
world for the two to three fold increase
that's a pretty big one we'll talk later
about ADHD there the numbers kind of
reverse it's two or three times more
frequent in boys than girls and about 70
percent of people who will have one
episode of depression will have another
one later on so the diagnosis in the dsm
book requires at least three of the
following for a period now what I wanted
to give you a feeling as you think about
this you know you're the doctor talking
to somebody and you know disturbed sleep
that how disturbed does it have to be
diminished appetite but how diminished
right loss of energy well we all have
periods where we're more sluggish or
more focused right I mean
so usually depression these things are
so extreme it's very obvious sometimes
you know it's at the edge and there's a
range of these things we know there's a
genetic predisposition if you have
identical twins 50% dizygotic 10% but we
know there's environmental factors so
it's very hard to figure out whether
diseases are getting more or less common
over time because especially in
psychiatric diseases the criteria that
defines those diseases change over time
so you don't know which it is
sensitivity to it you know 30 years ago
teachers never heard of autism now every
teacher is in kindergarten is watching
out for autism so it's spotted much more
quickly and consistently so you know
people say it's going up is it really
going up is it being detected more often
you know it's very hard to tell those
things apart but where evidence is
available since 1940 there's nearly a
ten-year drop in the average age of the
first incidence of depression so this is
ten-year drop that people are getting
better at spotting it and adolescence
instead of seeing an adolescent or child
is simply moody they're recognizing
depression or is the increased pressures
and childhood driving depression up at
an earlier age very hard to tell so
here's a video clip of some patients
describing their experience in two
so so people been trying to understand
my experiments what are the thought
patterns that are promoting depression
and one approach has been this dot probe
test we talked about that before I'll
remind you in a moment what that is but
basically it's to experimentally test
the idea there's a sort of cycle of a
negative thought and depression that
reinforces itself that you pay attention
to sad or bad things the more you think
about that things the worse you feel the
worse you feel the more you think about
bad things and this is sort of you know
downward spiral of grooviness
and another question that people are
very interested in is when you see these
kind of psychological mechanisms that
may contribute to depression are they
there for somebody who has never yet
been depressed but it's a risk factor
for becoming depressed or is it really a
consequence of the depression right if
you pay more attention to sad things is
that a risk for becoming depressed first
time ever or is that already part of the
disease process itself once it's hit so
here's a stop probe task we talked about
it before in regards to aging you see
two pictures a neutral one and a happy
one they disappear a dot appears behind
one or the other and you push a button
to indicate which side it's not all
you're doing is indicating recited sign
or you might get another pair of faces
with a negative expression and a neutral
expression it beneath one of them
sometimes it's a neutral sometimes a
negative a dot appears and then you can
look at the response times how quickly
people respond to the dot depending on
where the face was and the idea is the
faster you respond to a dot the more
your attention was drawn to a positive
neutral or negative face right because
if your attention is sitting there
already when the dot appears boom you're
ready to go if your attention is
somewhere else you'll have a slower
response and sure enough in patients
with depression specifically for sad
faces they have this bias response they
tend to respond quickly
when the dot appears with a negative
phase just has me so it's a way that
there's sort of the attention even for
such a trivial thing is drawn to the
negative it sits on the negative and so
now you can ask the question what about
girls who are born into families with a
history of depression so there I did a
general way at genetic risk for
depression but they are have never been
depressed themselves and so now we can
ask the question does this mode of
thinking or dwelling on the negative is
it apparent in these girls even before
they ever have depression and not all of
them will but you don't know yet which
ones will and which ones won't and sure
enough if looking at sadder happy faces
and here it gets pretty opposite for the
young girls who are have a low
likelihood of having depression no
family history they tend to dwell on the
happy faces and for the girls were born
in a family with depression they tend to
dwell in the negative faces so you can
see this mechanism focusing on the
negative
dwelling on the negative already even
before the child has ever had a peso de
depression so just for a moment let's
discuss does that mean is genetic or
environmental
so who are these girls of a high risk
for getting depression what does high
mean sorry to put you outside what is
high mean they're in a family where they
have a parent with depression okay so
you can't tell that maybe maybe having a
parent with depression ups the child's
focus on the negative because they had
some difficult things to deal with in
their family maybe they have a genes
that draw them to negative things or
maybe both you can't tell that apart
from these kinds of studies every once
in a while there's sort of a success
story in brain sciences and why it's
terribly important as this to this day
as one of the speakers said there's
people who think psychiatric disorders
are just for sissies that you just stop
being depressed just don't listen to
those voices right just stop washing
your hands and was very confusing about
this message is for people for example
who are addicted to substances or have
alcoholism we ask them to stop drinking
and stop taking drugs with support but
we say it's we think it's somewhere in
you to stop right so as you know you
were the right support we think it's
somewhere need to stop so it's kind of
hard where is that line right CBT is
getting people to find ways to think so
they're not anxious or not depressed
again we think it's in them with the
right kind of support so on the one hand
we ask people to get themselves
healthier with support right so it's
kind of tricky whereas if there's a line
of responsibility but I think one of the
triumphs of modern brain imaging is to
make visible the brain basis of
psychiatric disorders on average so
because there's no broken arm no broken
leg no tumor or anything like that right
that promotes discussion or
consideration as our psychiatric
disorders as real brain differences and
I can also tell you that unfortunately
we're not anywhere near where a house
can put up a picture of somebody's brain
and say oh this person certainly has
depression or schizophrenia or ADHD or
dyslexia or any difficulty that you know
of nobody can say that on the basis of a
single brain scan for a single person we
want to we're not there yet
but we can see on average differences
between people who have a diagnosis and
people who don't so here's a pet
positron emission tomography
top of the brain bottom of the brain
they found less activation in the so
called sub genuine anterior cingulate
the anterior cingulate is this cortex
that sits over the corpus callosum and
here in this bottom part of the anterior
cingulate less activation in patients
with depression than control subjects
and then looking at structure now
physical volume also reduced volume in
these areas in patients with both
unipolar and bipolar in this case
depression so now we have both a
structural difference on average and a
functional difference on average and
then there was a sometimes in psychiatry
that if you have brain banks when
patients pass away they donate their
brains to research and people said let's
go look in this area and people have
passed away so we can look at the
cellular level what's going on there we
can't see what brain imaging anything
close to cells but with post-mortem
analysis we can and there was a big
surprise the big surprise was when they
looked in this region there was a
reduced number of cells which goes with
the reduced volume and the reduced
activation but it wasn't the neurons
it was the glia and you go glia yeah we
haven't talked about glia for a long
time because neurons are the stuff that
compute the mind we all agree that glia
are essential for brain function so we
don't understand what that means that
these patients would have an equal
number of neurons but a reduced number
of glia we just don't know what that
means
but it was a big surprise and over time
I think maybe we'll think about that and
for the more imaging studies looking at
the anterior cingulate found that if you
looked at the pretreatment activity in
this brain region I'll show another
example in a moment you could see not
only changes that occur with treatment
but that difference is predicted which
patients would benefit more or less from
treatment so that all these convergent
areas about the importance of the
anterior cingulate cortex in depression
although nobody thinks that's the whole
story that the anterior cingulate is
part of a network of areas that are
compromised in depression and another
thing I think is a sort of an exciting
direction is if you each dot here is an
individual person here's how much they
improved better is down here this is the
patients who improve the most with
treatment the least with CBT treatment
and this is the initial activation so
you know it's telling you maybe that
these are the patients who really should
get CBT and maybe these are the patients
who didn't respond so much and maybe
they should get by the initial brain
measure some other form of treatments so
that's I think in exciting areas whether
we could develop enough understanding of
diversity among patients to understand
which patient might benefit from which
treatment but we're just at the
beginning of that kind of knowledge so
what about treatments for depression
well there's an S in 2005 - some years
ago - now but there's estimated 27
million people in the US there's you
know 10 billion now and more in sales
that's the drugs or CBT forms of
treatment or depression the most common
forms of treatment even with these
treatments so here's a message everybody
agrees I think reasonably that if you
know somebody with depression or you're
depressed yourself or anxiety but we're
talking about depression getting help is
a good idea
many people get helped but the help is
not nearly what we wish it were in the
field so in depression about half of
patients don't achieve remission they
still are depressed even after medicine
or behavioral treatment and even among
those who approve a lot there's still
residual symptoms it's not as if they
patients typically or often escape
entirely that but they can improve a lot
but the other thing is since nobody
knows which approach to take was which
patient by any scientific evidence it's
all trial and error so collect you know
finding a good treatment for person can
take months and by then some people just
give up and don't come back because
they're in the throes of the disease or
they just figure they're not going to be
helped it's all hitting this I have a
colleague in csail the computer science
department and we're doing research with
her and we say you know if you go to a
doctor now with depression or anxiety or
social anxiety disorder it's almost
completely random whether they assign
you to one treatment or another within
some broad constraints there's no
scientific basis for knowing what drug
you should get or a drug plus CBT or CBT
only it's completely random it's
depending on the physicians background
and intuitions there's no scientific
basis for knowing that so there's a lot
to be discovered so sometimes people try
to say well let's compare placebo
treatments to a medicine treatment -
cognitive behavioral therapy hears
responding to treatment improving so
better than placebo are both drugs but
eight weeks and CBT and then at sixteen
weeks there's even more of a gain and
they look very similar from patient two
on average across patients and if you
look over time now how after the
treatment is over how many people sort
of what the long-term picture is because
that you care about that I mean there's
two things getting people out of crises
and then keeping your head above water
it seems like the group that's you know
maintains the best response are the
people who have the CBT over longer
periods so you might say well why don't
we just give everybody CBT and part of
it is not everybody responds to that
some patients for example with severe
depression are talking about suicide you
don't feel like you can wait eight weeks
or 16 weeks to let a CBT process happen
some patients just don't have the energy
to go to sessions and work on things and
you need to rescue their from that so
there's all kinds of issues about you
know what what kinds of treatment
ultimately are practical and effective
for patients so in clinical trials when
they try a drug and we'll focus on drugs
for the moment there's a random
assignment we have patients with the
diagnosis are assigned either to a
placebo or a drug the physicians are not
supposed to know what it is response
means just getting better which is
valuable remission means that you're
qualify for having the disease anymore
how people decide whether you have
depression they take a full history but
they'll often use a some sort of rating
scale the most common one of the most
common is a Hamilton to say how severely
depressed are you so they can document
it at the beginning then give that to
you at the end and see how severely
depressed at the end so one thing to
know that's really interesting and
really a problem from the field is
there's incredibly strong placebo
responses in many studies the placebo
responses rival the response of the drug
itself and people have had huge debates
to this day about what that means and
it's not well understood so one idea is
that you have regression to some people
say you know nobody is getting better
that the entire thing is regression to
the mean from study entry and what does
that mean well when people have a drug
trials for depression
they say we want to treat people with
substantial depression that makes sense
right so you get people who have
substantially depressed now depression
is inherently a fluctuating disorder so
from your understanding of regression to
the mean what happens to a patient when
you get them with a really bad
depression score what's likely to be
their score next week
better or worse better okay all right so
you get people with a really low
depression scores you just sit back you
don't do anything and by because it's a
fluctuating disorder the chances are
that because you're getting them at low
points in they're going to get better
next week okay that's not a treatment
effect that's you're pushing you're
getting at them at a low moment by
definition so some people say wow these
studies could be full of that we say wow
look at this drug effect man's pushed it
up
yeah that's cuz you're getting people at
the worst moment they're going to go
back to their average which will be
better or another really interesting
thing is could our brains have
incredibly powerful responses to
placebos do we have in us
naturally-occurring healing mechanisms
you know that if we just really believed
in it then those can take over and could
we harness that could we harness these
naturally-occurring self-healing
capacities in people's minds and brains
to make them feels better so this is a
kind of typical average result you know
drug psychotherapy about the same
placebo pretty close and here's the no
treatment group but even this kind of a
picture has been challenged recently and
let me tell you what the challenges have
been and then let me tell you what I
take is the takeaway message but but but
it's not scientifically certain so what
one person did a meta-analysis and he's
totally arguing and let me tell you the
arguments pretty clever there's no
effect of a drug at all that typically
you get about 75 percent of a drug
effect from the placebo that's huge 75
percent from an inert substance sugar or
something like that okay 75 percent in
treating a severe psychiatric disorder
and he says that did that small
difference at 25 percent is due to this
and who even thinks of this until you
read this if you haven't been involved
in a drug study that apparent
differences are due to patients
realizing they're in the active drug
from the side effects okay so most
studies give you the drug
most drugs that treat things have
unpleasant side effects because their
potent things okay that aren't perfectly
targeted so they're saying oh it's
double-blind you self this patient
here's your pills you don't know if
they're placebo or drug and here's
Europeans you don't know if they're
placebo or drug but patients are
reasonably smart many have been through
treatment before and they know if
they're feeling nauseous and yucky and
all kinds of other stuff they got the
drug and if they take it and they don't
feel anything funny they got the sugar
placebo does that make sense does they
figure out in eighty percent of the time
they're accurate whether they got the
inert placebo or the drug because the
side effects tell them that not the drug
effect on the mind and that been the few
studies where they give you a placebo
that has peripheral effects that make
use nauseous like the drug then in those
couple of studies there's just been a
couple there's no difference between
placebo and drug so here's a position
that the entire thing is placebo and an
argument from this guy that we should
tell patients it's all placebo now why
do you think it's not necessarily a good
idea to tell patients even if it were
scientifically true yeah yeah yeah it's
a pretty good chance you've ruined it if
you hand them the pills and you go look
you know who knows it's all sugar but
you know give it a go
you know for a person who's in misery
right you know so they have to kind of
believe and it's kind of interesting
what is the biology of that belief all
right so um so that's one side of the
story another slightly less drastic
interpretation but also pretty strong is
that in a recent meta-analysis is that
that the drug effective a placebo only
occurs for the most severe depressions
the most severe depressions and the
depressions that are even considered
severe or moderate where you do want to
help people there's no difference
between the placebo and the drugs so my
only fear are telling you this is a you
know the last thing you want to do in
your life or somebody you care about
there's depression or anything like that
get them help because they are helped
and if it's placebo that's okay too and
if it's some you know your reputable
person without a degree but they're
really good at talking to people that's
good too okay though the evidence is
overwhelming that getting help helps
many people and not getting help with
people at greater and greater
it's overwhelming getting help is a
really good thing it's just that we
don't understand how the help works and
we know it doesn't help nearly
powerfully enough on a consistent basis
so now we're going to switch from from
depression to - to ADHD a disease of
childhood these are children who have
inattention hyperactivity percent of
cases impulsive moving around and jumpy
the diagnosis like everything is by
exclusion they make sure that there's
not some other problem the child's life
that's making them inattentive or
impulsive for example like abuse at home
its prevalence is a you know two million
or mores
tripled since nineteen eighty one
increase two and a half times since
ninety so it's sort of like the
discussions you hear now about autism
there was fantastic debates about ADHD
does it exist at all are people just
medicating kids to keep them lined up in
classrooms quietly listening to
lecturers like me you know is there a
real problem and there's incredibly
polarized debates about these things so
how does the clinician make the
diagnosis they look at the child they
talk to parents teachers and they sort
of fill out questionnaires and have a
list and I'll show you the kind of a
list the clinician has to work against
depending on studies and this is kind of
an interesting number ranges from about
2% to about 15% and you can say well how
could it possibly do that you know why
can't researchers get it right okay you
could take a half a percent off or two
or whatever it is but how can again it
depends so much on your criteria for it
for the diagnosis part of it a twos over
time these things changes you have
different versions of DSM and I
mentioned also countries professions
overnight in the same German population
doubled as DSM book got revised and
changed as a criteria okay is this the
correct criteria or these the correct
criteria and how would you know if you
have the correct criteria how would you
know if you got a right people just have
to have consensus as best they can guess
because there's no objective evidence
beyond reasonable interpretation so
about 3 to 5 percent of school-aged
children and the reason that people take
it seriously beyond these conceptual
debates is that children with ADHD that
is not treated
struggle a lot this huge variation of
course but but they predicts antisocial
behavior substance abuse adverse
occupational social adjustments are
people with ADHD who are phenomenally
successful there's probably some of you
in the class who've been diagnosed with
that in any group like this so it's not
you know the certain thing but on
average if you don't have other talents
and situations and support it's a big
risk factor for doing badly in life by
the ways that most people want to do
well the most common but not only
treatment is a Ritalin or
methylphenidate the ritalin is the
commercial name methyl open of the
generic name we know there's a genetic
piece about this you've heard it so many
times seven times higher rate within
families about 0.7 six heritability and
twin studies some candidate genes have
been identified involved in the
dopaminergic systems of the brain but in
a like with all neuropsychiatric
diseases in kind of a weak way it's not
like there's a gene if you have it you
have the disorder it's just a little
higher on average in populations okay so
here's the question kid comes in to you
you're the doctor and it's quite
interesting to talk to doctors about
this because in many medical settings
with the current economic environment
doctors are incredibly encouraged and by
for example their salaries to see
patients really fast okay the faster
they see them the more the health system
says yay we're productive alright so so
here's what they have to decide do you
have in attention because inattention
was one of the big criteria you have to
have at least six for at least six
months to agree that's maladaptive an
agent appropriate careless mistakes in
school or other activities I'm sure none
of us ever make careless mistakes right
typically the same thing tension in
tasks or play does not seem to listen
when spoken to directly does not follow
instructions to finish tasks difficult
organizing tasks and activities avoid
within this one avoids tasks engaging
sustained mental effort okay
loses things easily distracted by
extraneous stimuli forgetful and daily
activities
what five-year-old is not describable in
these ways right so you see how
challenging it is and it's not to take
it lightly because the kids who really
meet this really struggle over time
there's in many longitudinal studies
that on average children who meet these
criteria will struggle in many ways
so you know but look at all these are
there's nothing here like hearing a
voice right it's just like a kid but a
little more of it for your age
hyperactivity you fidget or squirm in
your seat leave you leave your seat in
the classroom we run about or climb
excessively you have difficulty playing
quietly you talk excessively blurts out
answers before questions are completed
so these our kids are tough on teachers
and classrooms the symptoms have to be
percept present before age of seven
persistent to more settings at home and
school for example typically and then
not because you don't hear well or cuz
you have allergies or other psychiatric
disorders and sometimes people talk
about both inattention and hyperactivity
or the combined type there is a thought
that the more frequent finding in boys
is because boys are more frequently the
hyperactive so their troublemaking in a
classroom they're jumping up and down
they're not listening to the teacher and
that girl's might be more on average
inattentive quiet and dreamy not taking
stuff in that's not a problem for
classroom management so there's a
thought that girls might be under
diagnosed because of the way it's
expressed in boys and girls but there's
a huge source of evidence that if left
completely untreated rates of depression
anxiety substance abuse academic failure
work problems family problems emotional
stress much higher in children work
there's no attempt to treat or manage
ADHD there's a huge amount of evidence
for this so one of the sort of most
famous studies in psychiatry of in
developmental psychiatry of directly
comparing individuals on a treat of
behavioral and drug treatments it was a
study called the MTA study it was done
in many different sites all put together
with a huge number of children 14 months
they got medication management alone
behavioral treatment alone a combination
of both or routine community care so
they said what happens when we give you
better behavioral treatment or what more
careful medical management on the drugs
or you go back to your standard
community care and what people found was
this that medication management alone
here's what they did in those conditions
they've aside dr. monthly for 30 minutes
they would move the drug amount up or
down they would
if it seemed to be sedating the child
too much they make it less if it was not
working enough and make it more and they
would talk a lot with a child in the
parent so that was the medication
management more active than you
typically glad in medical interactions
behavioral treatments that will involve
an eight-week summer camp or you got the
two of them together or you did we were
sent back to your community and got the
regular care from a regular doctor that
people typically get so and the big
outcomes were that the best thing was to
have the medical management alone or a
combination of the two and in some cases
you would get lower doses of medications
if you got the behavioral treatment so
you could say and for many years I heard
lecturers who were expert in this field
saying the definitive thing is the
medication pretty much does it all maybe
the behavioral treatment at something
the behavioral treatment by itself
didn't add much this was what everybody
was taught but they kept following these
people and here's what they found eight
years later after the study was over no
difference in which group you were in
about 60% of kids stopped taking
medication did the family decided to
stop where the doctors had it stopped
and there was no difference between
those who did or did not stop taking
medication in terms of difficulties in
life so now this is very complicated
because people always say like what is
the long-term effects of taking Ritalin
and children what is the long-term
effects and you go well you know you
could say the first interpretation is
this as well since it didn't make any
difference the drug has no effect at all
right you take the drug you don't take
the drug you have the same outcome
you know 14 months with something but
eight years it doesn't matter but of
course who's more likely to stop taking
the medication kids who are doing better
or kids who are doing worse who's more
likely to stop probably on average kids
are doing better right
so maybe what you're really maybe no
difference is some kids were improving
for other reasons and the kid and so
really the kids who got the medications
caught up with them because of the
medications and you can't tell those two
things apart so it's just incredibly
hard to know with certainty what the
right thing to do is in any long-term
view because you can control for 14
months what people do if they're willing
to let you do that but you can't control
it over years they go back to their own
complicated lives and sorting out what
the treatment did versus the rest of
their life
is really hard so Tyler if we could do
the VCR movie here's a example of a kid
with um ADHD in some discussion about
that you know amazingly I can tell you
that even those are as good about a bit
as good as you can do
there is no behavioral test you can give
like this that's better than 50/50 at
separating an ADHD child from other
children okay so you can be part of the
story but many many many children will
not be identified this way even though
they're having real problems with school
at home I want to say two things about
the video game people as they noted here
sometimes ADHD diagnoses are tough
because when kids come in to a new
situation a doctor's office and you
doctor an evaluation it gets their
attention and they look more focused
okay so some people and people have
notice such kids with ADHD seem to do
quite well when they have an
entertaining video game which is easier
to enjoy right the most things so so
they actually did the study to ask how
long does an ADHD kid play a video game
versus a kid without ADHD and when
they're both playing video games still
the HD ADHD kid plays for less long
right so it's not that it takes it away
but it in many ways obfuscates the
difference so um so what was that one
interesting question is what is the
right dose because we said the
treatments where they titrated the dose
where you went to a doctor frequently
and they said let's push it up let's
push it down let's get the dose that's a
right for the child how what is that
number so here's a paper although back
from 1977 here's placebo here's a small
dose here's a large dose and they
measured three different things they
measured how well you did in terms of
the teacher ratings the teachers say
how's the kid doing that's the open bars
okay so the teacher said here's how the
kids doing they go well this is even
better and they go this is even the best
okay so the teachers are saying the more
drug the better here's an objective
measure of learning performance by those
children the same children better worse
so you see you know as we go back to the
ideas that came out of the prefrontal
lobotomies completely different topic
everybody pretty much in the field
degrees of these drugs help these kids
on average
but think about the complications of
what the right doses for the teacher the
biggest dose is best and why do you
think that's likely to be for the
teacher doing classroom management with
the thirty kids
why does a big dose seem best yeah yes
yeah yeah II was gonna say same thing
yeah for them as the kid is not
fidgeting not jumping around distracting
the other kids so a slightly over
sedated kid seems like a triumph and it
can be to a parent also like listening
to me
you know but it but objective learning
measures this is optimal and this is
overdosing so you know I think we'd all
agree this is the one that matters most
of all but you can see you know you
don't often have this kind of
measurement often the doctor says what
does a teacher think what does a parent
thing and the kid will end up over here
because that's what seems most you know
correct to the eyes of the teacher or
the parent the biggest change in the
child's behavior so for the last couple
mins I was talking about brain imaging
in regards to ADHD so we talked about
the idea that the cerebro cortex you
have too much of it too many neurons and
over-connected
and that what it is to grow the adult
brain you have is to eliminate neurons
and synapses that are not functionally
valuable you're picking out the most
valuable players of your neurons and so
you can say there's a peak age at which
you go up and then you go down you
consider that peak to be a sort of
milestone of development and you can see
here in the dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex here's the front of the brain
here's a delay in ADH children they take
an average two years longer to reach
that peak than do typically developing
kids but there's no difference at all in
primaries of Medicine three cortex so
you couldn't might imagine and systems
that are the inputs of sensory
stimulation from the world an ADHD child
is typical for parts of the brain that
regulates like I'm not going to pay
attention to that I'm going to focus on
this that's slower developing and you
can see how that might lead to
inattention or easy distractibility so a
two-year delay in the development on
average of prefrontal cortex a structure
I talked with you before let me just
remind you of this that if we look at
rewards systems anticipation of a reward
coming up in a few moments activates the
nucleus accumbens and animals and humans
this is in humans that's as a patient of
a reward and the same system that's
measured here goes on to the medial
prefrontal cortex and that system turns
on when you get the reward
so one thing anticipates and one thing
responds when you get the reward and
there's been some slightly divergent
studies in ADHD but one suggestive one
is this so here's the control subjects
anticipating the reward here's the ADHD
individuals not it you know also
anticipating the reward but not showing
any app to any activation it's as if now
remember the reward is this you get a
signal that tells you in a few moments
if you push a button you're going to get
a dollar
this is not like study now and then
you'll if you complete college you get
to go to medical school it's not delayed
gratification
it's anticipating reward coming up in
about 10 seconds and at least in these
patients
it doesn't drive the system it's as if
delayed gratification we're not having
any traction with these brains on the
other hand then you find out if you got
it or not because sometimes they tricky
when you don't get it
orbital frontal response and controls
and much more an ADHD patient so if this
picture is true or at least true for
some patients imagine the consequence of
not being able to hold yourself
anticipating reward to being overly
responsive to whether you got it or not
you'd be stimulus bound right you
couldn't hold yourself back it's not
it's not helping you develop delayed
gratification and here's one more thing
that people ask which is if you have
because now there's some evidence about
this if you give ritalin for a while
does it slow the development of the
cerebral cortex and I won't go into the
details here but the answer is it does
not so people worried like if we keep
giving you ritalin for some more years
are we affecting brain structure and the
evidence is clear you know objective
evidence that it is not so so I think a
lot of people feel like if the
medication is helpful there's very
little evidence there's harmful side
effects weirdly enough riddle and
come back to this just in a minute is
one of the least problematic medications
in psychiatry and frequently helpful so
the last fMRI study I want to show you
is this let's say you gave riddle and
not only to children with ADHD who are
taking it but also typically developing
children who've never taken ritalin
because they're typically developing and
how do their brains respond to that so
here's some ADHD children with children
and children without a th D and here's
the tasks they perform sometimes they
push a push a button every time a letter
appears you know they're having a whole
bunch of letters here push push push
push but they're told when it X appears
don't push so you're tricking the
subjects because you're getting a habit
going what would people call prepotent
sounds push push push push
oops hold yourself back okay what people
call go go don't go and that's hard to
do for a kid it's harder to do for
somebody with ADHD to control the
impulse to push and so you measure
bringing and here's the behavior and
then let me tell you the issues so
here's the percent false alarms this is
when you push for the X you should have
held yourself back here's the control
here's the ADHD children making more
impulsive errors overall harder to
control themselves and stop themselves
from pushing the for that X when they're
off Ritalin they make more mistakes when
they're on okay so but look at these
kids who have no ADHD and never took it
because they have no reason to take it
they perform better but look at the drug
effect just the same size and this is
not the only study that is found the
giving typical children ritalin will
make them perform better on cognitively
demanding tasks they're typically not
done so well by children is by adults so
the psychiatrist we work with on the
study said wow we used to think that if
we gave somebody ritalin and they
behaved better we knew we gave the right
treatment okay but it's not clear that
these kids aren't behaving better okay
they have no problem and there's no
reason to give them the medication and
step through this if you look in the
brains of where the riddle is affecting
things and lots of
brain the control subjects and the ADHD
children look alike the only part of the
brain that looks really different is in
the basal ganglia part of the brain
that's involved in habits and impulse
controls affect also implicated in OCD
that we talked about before it's an area
that's full of dopaminergic systems it's
an area that ritalin binds to when you
look inside the brain and animals and
here what was found was this so this is
a behavioral difference you saw before
so if you look in the basal ganglia
here's the control children off the
medication and then on the medication
here's the ADHD showing this opposite
response so here's the only place where
the responses are different between the
control children the ADH to children and
you can see in a way the medication is
normal so called normalizing the
activation so here's typical kids just
being themselves knodel and here's
children with ADHD not treated and now
you can see now look how similar they
get with the treatment okay so in this
part of the brain and it's an opposite
effect when the typical children get the
drug activation go down the 80s children
goes up so this is a part of the spar
the brain seems like it's an important
part of the story and also how the
medication influences somebody so the
last thing I want to talk about for two
minutes and including the chapter in
this or three minutes is you know the
struggle that people have what's the
boundary between treating and outright
disease and manipulating normal
variation so for example you know here's
the average height in the u.s. of men
and women huge debates about whether
people who are on a very you know sort
of uh are projected to have a very short
stature in adulthood should they get
growth hormone or not
when argument is no while you think
about it some are some parents will feel
like my kid might struggle give the kid
a break you could do something about it
you don't have to you know do that how
about sadness and depression you know if
you're somebody somewhat sad should they
be should they get CBT or do they have
to be in dark depression where's the
boundary between shyness and social
anxiety or where as a kid doesn't follow
directions when do you say that's a
kidnapping attention to ADHD so one of
the big surprises in a
has been that on when people of and you
guys can tell me in a moment when people
pull things you never know how accurate
these are us in some polls seven percent
of university students without ADHD say
they take methylphenidate to help them
focus and concentrate on their studies
and we've been more disturbing to
scientists in one study in nature twenty
percent of scientists that they do it so
I I'm not asking you to turn yourself in
but this is my little poll of
undergraduates in the world out there
besides what I read them magazines so is
their moderately widespread use of it by
people who are not you know prescribed
directly themselves or is it pretty rare
we're rare video here right okay and you
know and then and then what is the right
thing you know we're we're and all this
will will people debate about this I
think there's no debate that for people
really suffering you want to help them
but where should the line be drawn
between you know helping those in
despair and boosting those you know in
the middle so the last example I want to
give you just for a minute is this
chapter from a from a man who mistook
his wife for a hat because of this
question about boosting experience so
this is a woman of 19 and Tasha K she
comes to the clinic after her 88th
birthday she began to change
she felt thrilled she was extremely well
people said she had changed from being
shy to pleure tatius giggling telling
jokes at age 88 she had this huge
transformation that turns out she has
syphilis what she calls cupid's disease
but she's quite enjoying the change in
personality she's disinhibited and
having a good time okay it's like the
small bit of alcohol that loosens you up
but all the time without any of the
downside right and then they said well
should we treat it because she got the
disease at an age when penicillin was
not widely given and they discovered
happily that if they treat the
penicillin and protects her medically
but she because the brain change from
the neurosyphilis has occurred she
remains very happy all the time okay so
so yeah if somebody could give you a
drug that could make you very happy all
the time you know bad idea good idea
anyway so you could think about it
thanks very much
you